President Trump has made his first
public tribute to John McCain after two
days of near silence the Maine flag over
the White House is now flying at
half-staff joining others in Washington
and around the country the White House
flag had been raised to full staff
yesterday morning that complied with the
US flag code but many people saw it as a
snub from a president who had
long-standing disagreements with McCain
after refusing to comment during the day
mr. Trump offered his appreciation for
McCain's service last night we shashank
is at the White House with the
president's belated tribute Lygia good
morning good morning John there was an
expectation for President Trump to set
aside his rocky relationship with
Senator McCain to pay less respects to
the American hero but that did not fully
happen until the president faced a
mountain of pressure but the White House
insists he made that decision to reload
the flag on his own our hearts and
prayers are going to the family of
Senator John McCain facing mounting
criticism president Trump finally
offered remarks on the death of Senator
John McCain on Monday night we very much
appreciate everything that Senator
McCain has done for our country the
shift in the president's tone came after
urging from senior aides reportedly John
Kelly and included a presidential
statement and proclamation to lower the
US flag until McCain is laid to rest on
Sunday despite our differences on policy
and politics at three separate White
House events the president dodged
questions about why he initially sent
only a tweet that did not include
anything about McCain's service and why
the flag outside the White House was
flying high it flew at half-staff on
Saturday night and Sunday but was fully
raised for most of the business day
yesterday until it was reload in the
late afternoon following bipartisan
outcry anybody who any way tarnishes the
reputation of John McCain deserves a
whippin and a demand from the nation's
largest wartime veterans service
organizations
the American Legion mr. Trump once
slammed President Obama for hesitating
to lower flags after five service
members were killed in Tennessee saying
at the time this disgraceful omission is
unacceptable and yet another example of
our incompetent politicians last night
McCain's brother noted the chilly
history between the two men this Trump
not even addressing when John was sick
and dying and this refusal to call him a
hero I mean it sounds petulant it sounds
childish a senior administration
officials tell CBS News that the
president's statement on McCain speaks
for itself though it does not address
the two-day delay in releasing it the
rest of the statement though says plenty
the president listed all the people who
will represent the White House at
upcoming celebrations of McCain's life
himself not included Yale all right
recharging thank you very much